[Music]
using this it can actually integrate
with our app that we have designed
so
but like what makes you think that it is
a very valid incentive it is expensive
it will flat out the liabilities
downstream
[Music]
i think one of it was that our ideas
were not
apt for the competition or rather it was
very simplified it was something that
was already in the market and so we were
quite demoralized at the same time
because we were going nowhere we had
multiple ideas there was no direction he
and kihong brought in a lot of
industrial examples and experiences
which were very very precious to
the students so by engaging in this
program they are actually shown what is
actually happening around the world
outside the classroom setting
[Music]
it's a competition collaborated between
su td and sia with old aircraft parts
which cannot be used anymore then
through that we have to come up with
ideas for products that will bring value
to the old parts
we let the tools surface the problems
along the way for them to realize it is
very common for anyone even sometimes
for other designers to fall in love with
your own creation you're very resistant
to
criticism you're very very unwilling to
be nudged you know in other ways
some of the products were not actually
how it was on internet when we googled
it to like have a view and the sizes
were different so going down touching
the materials knowing what the materials
exactly were gave us a good insight i
feel that through this project it really
helped us take something that we don't
usually take to recycle not like
newspapers and everything but using this
kind of high-end products we try to make
a better thing
[Music]
we're working on a planned bag that's
like to promote sustainability petagon
as a whole it's just a place where you
can buy a fully customizable pet play
set that allows you to just let loose
your creativity and build what you want
to see in your house we're actually
coming from the angle where there's a
prototype related to the end user that
you're actually talking to so the
emphasis was more for the students to
learn from mistakes to basically right
you fail early and you succeed sooner i
don't think it's fair to say that we
failed
we just didn't succeed there's a
difference there there's a there's a
difference there
yeah it's true that a lot of times
people will say that oh you're born with
that creative sparks but we have also
observed that through programs like this
it has allow students to be given the
platform to to exercise their decorative
muscles and to see how creativity itself
can be enhanced when they work with
their peers
so that's something that i thought this
composition kind of allowed them to
build this into their dna
[Music]
you